みなさんこんにちは
当日かて dx 信州にバーシティ
あの最初対抗すごかったですよね聞かれました
忍者みましたこういっしょ安となりましたよね
いられました
いいですねぼくその頃部屋にこもって一人でこの練習してました
ずっどうしようと思いない
こんな今くだらない話ししてのも何でかって言うとすれば何話すんだったっけ
今一生懸命思い出すこと一緒です
8そうだマッサージさん入ってくれたとおり今日皆さんに共有したいことはもう
たくさんの人に応援してもらって
でやりたいことを実現する方法これをちょっと9位したいと思います
まあ何かというと私は紹介立ててレックス松本の代表してますまさにこういうイベン
トっていうのは本当にたくさんの応援をいただかないと
まあ一人で想いつけてもねたくさんの応援いただかないと実現できないですね
なんでまあその絵をちょっと学んだことを共有したいと思っています
この中ですいませんこういうイベントをやってみたい人って言いますか
いないいないのいなかったすいませんって買っちゃうかもしれないですけど
アイマスでよかったですまぁ今日はこんな感じでちょっとくだらないこと言うんであの
受けてくれないとショボーンとして帰ろうかなとしますんであのこれギャグかもと思っ
たら嘘前向いてもらってください
8すいませんなどで本当にこれ応援がないところとできないですね
で今日すいませ時間の関係があるんでお金という形の応援をちょっと
中心に話そうと思っています
じゃあすいませんどうやって応援してもらいますかね
どうやって応援お金の形でオンしてもらえばいい
プロフィット利益得つまりお金を出してくれたらそれ以上の得なことが愛あなたの
ところに行きます
そうやって説得できればお金もらえる簡単ちゃん
僕も最初はそう思いましただからてデックス松本
こんなすごいイベントなんですこんな意義のあるイベントなんですどうぞお金出して
ください
したらそのイベントで企業さんであればロゴが出ます
剪定効果ありますいやーイメージアップの効果がありますよ
そんなことを言ってお金を集め移しました
でもねあれなんですよ
だって第一回のイベントなんです
効果ありますよつってまあ何の裏付けもないからて方です
世の中そんな甘くないですほとんどお金集まりませんでした
だけどねまったく応援してもらうのがゼロだったわけじゃないんですね
こんな状況でも応援してくれる人いました
なんで僕ちょっと考えたんですねこの人たちなんて応援してくれたんだろうこんな状況
なるん
そして気づいたことを2つありました
一つは私がその人たちに何で僕テックス松本したいんですか
でペックス松本してどうしたいんですかいわゆるビジョンというやつですけどねそれ
だけじゃなくてそのビジョンに関係する
私自身のまあ人生反映したストーリーを一緒に語ってたんですね
まあビジョンとストーリーと言われてもパットまあこのここにおいての方わかんないと
思います
なんでちょっとね時間かかるんですけど僕が実際にお話しした
まあテレックス松本のビジョンに結びついた
総理ちょっとお話だしてもらえます8私にはまぁそこにオイルですよ
中学生の息子がいます
ん
彼は
自閉症という障害個性を持っています
まあ親としてすごく気になることがいっぱいあってそれはこの日本では経済的に自立し
ている障害者っていうのは非常に少ないということです
こんなデータがあるのでちょっと披露します
障害者が働いて賃金いただきます給料もらえますそれを平均します
障害があるのでまぁ国から年金いただけます
その合計の金額
実は生活保護を受けている人に支給される金額よりもずっと低い
生活保護より少ないどういう意味だということですよね
なんでそんな給料低いんですかっ
障害者ってをとっているんです
ちょっとその時僕なりにずっと考えたんですね
で思いついたことがあるんですそれはまっさっきね関口さなトークでもあったすごい
ことできる障害者いるんですよ
それをみんな知らないからじゃないかなそう思いました
のうちの息子も
ちょっと自慢しちゃいますがすごい
電車運転出来ませんよこれは動かない電車にちょっと素晴らしいもらって写真撮った
だけです
だけど電車に関してホントすごいんです
例えばブルートレイン
まあ今ねどんな時代背景にあのブルートレインが生まれたかで今は全部廃止されちゃい
ましたね
なんで廃止されたか彼なりの観点で一時か
まぁそれぐらいずーっと理路整然と語ることができます
だからなんだと思うよねそして
数字すごい強いですまあ今入ったブルートレイン例えばあさかぜ後何年の何月何日に
走り出して何年の何月何日に廃止された
そんなのもパッと出てきます
数字の話ちょっと面白い話がんで1個広させてください
5月3日に行ったんですねて dx 松本
僕はまあを5月3日大事な日なんで朝ケア売れておきました
そう言うと姉もうカレームすでに起きていますん
で満面の笑みでおとうさんおはようこう言ってくれるんですね
だが僕もおはよん
2 tone 管理行為ですよお父さん今日は5月3日だよね
増大を5月3日だからお父さんにとって大事な日なんだよ
うん1962年5月3日
何か嫌な予感してるんですよ
その日はね東京の三河島で脱線事故があって160人死んだんだよお前
ん
大事な日って言っただろうみたいな
すごくばうねるでしょ大蛇言ってたんだやだけどねその字小金屋もいいんですよ
まあこういう風にしてポンポンポンポンかに数字できるんですねまあこれがどう仕事や
ビジネスにつながるかって問題はありますけれども
まあ恋すごいとこあるんです
なんですごいところを知らないからそのすごいとこ生かす仕事がそういった人たちと
行かない
当然自分たちの一番武器を生かせないんだから給料低くなりますよ
あそれが原因だだからそう知ってもらえばいい
そう思いました関口さんの遠くにありましたよねサヴァン症候ぐ
あんなすごい力があるのに最後どうでした仕事に反している人ゼロでしたよね
あれが現状なんです誰が知ってもらう
じゃあ知ったらほんと変わりますくっんすいませんこれも僕の話をさせてください
嘘は自閉症ってわかる前の私
僕の人生に障害者は存在しないのと同じです
ん
タブンネ小学校のクラス中学校のクラスいたと思いますけど覚えてませんん
たぶんね大人になって電車に乗りましたいたはずですけど気づいています
いやもっとついませんちょう時期にこのバカ言っちゃいますが多分もっとひどかったと
思いますあの頃の自分に障害者が助けてくれってきたらいやごめん俺忙しいん
避けていたという
つまりね知る前の僕っていうのは本当に障害者のことを知らない
知ろうとしないまさに今のこの社会そのものの一員だったん
じゃ知った後ところだったんでしょこれもちょっと話ししまう
知る前の私はもうそんなんだから当然いい学校へ行っていい会社に入るのは一番いいな
と思っています
ちょっと自慢話するともう北千葉出身なんですが千葉県でも有名な新学校に行って
で大学も言って転職しておそらく皆さんも名前が聞いたことのある会社に入ってますん
でそこでやりがいのある仕事をして
まあ将来結婚してくれる女の人も見つけてん
そしてシリコンバレーに海外赴任前させてもらいました
それが知る前私ですけどねシッターとふっと思ったんです
そういう生き方をしている僕に
それとは違う道を生きる息子やその障害者に何か教えられることがあるだろう
考えたんですねないんですよ
だからふっ決断しちゃいましたん
そのいい会社やめて
じゃあその今まで自分が歩いてきた人生と違う
多分息子や障害者が歩くであろう道を自分の人生
まぁちょっと前ですよねちょっと前を自分の人生で実験して気づいたこと
あるいは学んだことを教えてやろうそう思って会社辞めちゃったんです
バカですよまあ後悔はないですけど実際大変だったと思います
嫁さんもいるんで懇親会で聞いてみてください
まあそんな風な感じでまあ汁ってことでこんだけ変わりますだから
やっぱりね大事なんですよ
だからちょっと寝てデックスの趣旨が違うんで難しいかもしれませんけどこういった
場所で障害者がすごいことをこうやってみんなの前で
プレゼンを通して披露するそしてそのすごいことを知ってもらって
そして
それをなんて患者それを活かした仕事やビジネスにつなげるきっかけにする
そして最終的には
自立につなげたい
つまりテックス松本って本当にこういった僕のビジョンを
まぁなんと実現するための本当に僕の人生の実兄の本当に最初の最初の一歩だったん
です
なんてことですねまぁ最初に応援してくれるって人には言ってました
これが一つ目の気づきです
二つ目
実はねまあ裏を返すとすごいった話みんなにしているわけではありませんでした
前から知っている人だったりあるいは初対面の人でも話しやすい安心できるこの人が
いいかなっていう人にしか入ってませんでした
当然さっきお金を取ろうと思って行ったところには一切話してませんですよ
だけどその結果まあお金集まってないんですよいや今お話したとおりて dx 松本僕
にとってすごい大事なイベントです
そう思ってたらちょっとだけ勇気が出てきました
今3の話もういいやどう思われてもいい
失敗してもいいですこの思いを率直に回りにさえてみよう
そう思ったんですね
ところがまあそう思ってつまりも
会社どこ行ってもですねこんなお金くればこんなとこなことがありますよと話しあ
あまりしないというのもほとんどします
そんなことよりも私こんな人間です
こんな人減がこんな社会松本にしたくて
テックス松本ってイベントをやりたいです
だから応援してくださいできればお金の形だと嬉しいです
そんな感じで安全にアプローチを変えてきます
ん
面白いことにこんなちょっとしたもの雪が多分周り伝わった-9
スタッフのみんなも自分なりの自分のテックス松本ストーリーをつくって回りに応援お
願いしてくれるようになります
一つちょっと紹介させてください
8彼は副代表の国だけさんです彼は島地震大の医学部生でしたん
在学中に地域活性化とかそういうことに興味があったので彼は本当に積極的そういう
イベントとかサークルに参加しました
そこで参加している地元の人おじいさんおばあさんにいつもこう言われるそうです
どうせさ卒業したらあなた松本写真集からいなくなるんでしょ
実際彼今卒業して県外で研修医で頑張っています
なんで全くその通りなんで最初そのことに対して答えることができなかったぞ
しかしテレックス松本の活動していくうちにこういうふうに言えるようになったそう
です
そのとおりです私は一つ行したら松本が出てきます
だけど松本には何か残して恩返ししたいです
だから僕の分身としてテックス松本というイベントを置いてきます
このイベントが2回3回4回5回10回と繰り返されることで
まずも10日制化させるんです
だから続けたいんですそのためにはこの第1回必ず成功させたいんです
応援してくださいこんな国だけばのてデックス
松本ストーリーを回りに語って応援をお願いしてくるようになります
面白いですよね
まぁこんな感じで本当にちょっとした勇気が周りに役を与えて
状況もしかしたら帰るかもし変えることができるかもしれん
これが
その時ちょっと気づいた2つ目でしたんほんのちょっとの行きですよね
さあ結果どうなったと思います
イベント5月です
1月の段階でほとんどお金ないんですよ
で
こういうふうにストーリーをもとに応援お願いした結果2月3月4月
この4巻あ3カ月で
100万円を超えるお金が集まりましたん
お金だけじゃないんですよね例えばこの写真にある
奥の方に松本城とか北アルプスのこういう舞台の飾りがあります
これもねすいませんお金が足んないんでタダでやってくださいっていう無茶なお願い
ですね聞いてくれる
こういう加工してくれる会社がありました左にちょっと経ってるかねちょっと見づらい
かも知れスタッフの
t シャツ着ていますこのちー冊も t シャツをプリントしたり作ってくれる会社
さんがタダで作ってくれません
こんな感じでたくさんの応援をいただいて本当にこの写真のように
fedex 松本実現することができました
今回は息子とが障害者もまあこの発表者として出すことはいろんな事情でできなかった
んですけど松本で
で dx をスタートさせることができて本当にこれが大事なヒップだ
たと思っています
この写真のように本当にお金とかそれ以外にも沢山の応援を頂きました
今日ちょっと時間の関係でそれを話しできないのが本当に申し上げも行けないし
この時応援してくれた人日本ところ場を借りて感謝したいと思います
震災後です八つ最後になりましたん
今日皆さんに持って帰ってもらいたいこと
私は心から伝えたいこと
何かを実現するために応援してほしい
そのために必要な2つのことです一つはビジョンですよね
どうしたいのか
そしてその結果どんな社会を作りたいのかもちろんこのビジョン大事です不可欠ですで
もそれだけでは短ないかなと思います
そのビジョンに関係するまああなたの人生もそのままさらけ出した
あなただけの story これがナイトビジョン
他人ごとになっちゃいますもう2なるきれいごとになっちゃいます
だけど逆にこのストーリーがあるからこそビジョンがあなたこういうのものになるん
です
だからそのビジョンに対して誇りもてるし情熱が持てます
きっとそれが人の心を動かすそう思います
そしてもう一つ
これを外に本当に語るこんなちょっとの勇気です
もう一度言いますあなたしか話せないストーリーがあるから
美女に誇りが持てるしそれに自信がもてます
だからほんのちょっとの勇気を出してそれを赤裸々に外に語ってください
そうすることで相手に情熱が伝わり
多分耳を傾けてくれるはずですそう私は思います
もうちょい最初誰でもいいです本当身近な人から飾ってください
そしてもしよろしければこの後の懇親会
ほんのちょっとです勇気を出して私に聞かせてください
きっと記念すべき
実現への第一歩となるはずです
ご静聴ありがとうございました
voodoo